In Malaysia, two women are officially charged with the murder of Kim Jong Nam,...
...the half-brother of North Korea's leader,...
...after his assassination at a Malaysian airport last month.
In Italy, Mount Etna, a volcano located on the east coast of Sicily,...
...spews fire and lava as it erupts for a second night.
In Somalia, the appointment of former aid worker and oil executive...
...Hassan Ali Kheyre as prime minister, is approved by parliament.
In Yemen, internally displaced Yemenis from Mokha...
...continue to find shelter in camps in Hodeidah,...
...where they say they lack food and assistance.
And finally from China, monks and devotees participate in traditional activities...
...at the Beating Ghost festival to ward off troubles and expel evil spirits.